yeah welcome to this video let's go for
a couple of blitz games here three
minutes and we've got a French always
whoops what g3 this is ram move okay
this should probably is still okay it's
okay 92 amazing okay let's try some some
funny stuff probably play age four okay
then our Knight to f5 aha ok I'll
regroup this to be six let's see what
what is big ideas why does okay of
course it's not like he's playing
playing a nonsense or anything but still
the Sun look at a bit weird to me with
g3 okay so i should don't have a fairly
solid position nevertheless okay a form
do I play for not sure if I would get it
back ok let's try to exchange some
pieces would be helpful okay prevents 95
song but no problem now I get before for
my night the King side is completely
closed after you play deaf for which I
found a bit surprising why would you
play a form to kill your own bishop you
will never get anything going here
anyway like f5 or g4 this moves are not
not them on in the next step couple of
moves just Park the King on g7 and down
should be fine yeah the idea would be to
play b5 still at some point it probably
wants to get the night over here to f2
to d3 something like this but I will
play b5 next move on laughter after this
so my night will come to before this
second night also and I always have some
point to check with the a fault on yeah
that's not doing much i think i can go
rooks yet c8 next move okay just
returned yeah now i can probably even
double on the c4 why not it's really far
away to get anything on the on the on
the King side okay to see if Bishop f1
coming maybe okay so probably I should
intensify on AC 3 night a 2 I can play a
rootsy to tell just take here Knight
takes rook see one should be
ty morning we should see too many long
shouldn't be too bad on a phone yeah
this bishop has made quite some career
here I'm improving to to be 4i can just
take it What nonsense this wasn't
completely unnecessary why did I do that
okay yeah this should be fine again
controlling the position
just trying to win the porn here white
for it on time yeah no it's it's winning
with the new porn promoting made it a
bit bit too loud some counter place what
I want to try to say this should be a
should be really over you team get some
some kind of kind of play going maybe
here need to do something something else
not quite sure okay let's say a try from
new game okay another one year for okay
let's play you five as I do often and
become an Italian game what do three
quite them quite them slow long time
maneuvering way to play black [ __ ]
making all those moves d6 enter also h6
all very useful little moves so yeah he
can claim this one to make sure that
those pieces I exchanged if the the
night moves again just castle now
yeah of course this is some very young a
very solid position for both sides
actually it's very difficult to make any
kind of from immediate progress young
here I've got them more than one
possibility i can take on v3 but i can
also one could also play just the Queen
move here now it's got 95 I've been
taking what's the simpler solution but I
want to try to get something here 95 I
could take with the bishop and um it
would at least be a little bit of an
imbalance of course I'm learning a bit
up on time yeah just a bit yeah now I
could think of d5 after he moved his
night away come on to do something here
bit down anyway and tell him okay this
is interesting so now I could could
think of d for I could also take taking
of course being them being the simpler
option or maybe loop the idea let's play
rock da it shouldn't be too bad you can
play a 922 G for now okay didn't what
about default is really bad m 9 a-5
maybe mean yeah probably at play 95
and okay let's all protect the 51
somewhere out there there's no direct
technical problem I may be taking a
light see for moon I didn't think about
this all right stick here hi one and
protect us this pawn all right Queen d6
next yeah this wasn't really planned but
it doesn't look too bad I hope I hope at
least okay he tries to open it up
understandably taking you for now and
take thee for whom what happens if i
take dy probably five right okay let's
take here must must speed up and hope
that down this stuff is holding
rook takes Queen c7 hopefully it's still
okay okay yeah he tries he wants to take
on g6 and I understand i took with the
porn i didn't really appreciate that
this is protected various various
various man i didn't i don't think i was
really in trouble I've done tons of
course very helpful for him yeah okay
yes it's alright it yeah Queen g6 and
time time pressure I didn't see that
this is possible really i thought i
would pin the pawn um I don't think it's
so terrible computer says just equal man
just taking on d5 and equal probably
whoop dat six something like this yeah
okay I was worse I was worth no doubt
about it but I thought that the worst
would be over but it's difficult with
the time okay try for a new game this of
course now was so what's most terrible
71
ya hear what white certainly wants a
somewhat better button so it's not a big
deal yeah the computer is very
cold-blooded that wants to play Knight
f40 and claims Black is fine yeah it's
difficult for a human to play this here
I thought you would just take and this
is certainly better for white a bit with
the bottom that Kings Kings side and we
we King in general yeah I'm just take
him ok have a new game let's see deform
ok Knight f6 keeping my options open and
tell me ok c5 he doesn't want to advance
it seems ok let's grab him and now each
was supposed to yeah english opening I
can play g6 let's see what what is doing
now Knight c3 ok so we get into a Murat
see whined let's see if he sm he knows
something about this and down what kind
of setup he chooses ya f three sm
unknown in accuracy am 26 now sets white
some problems I Queen a five hits now
turkey you must play Knight b5 now's the
only move freely to to justify what is
doing I can retreat to c3 and grant like
just an extra move
p5 is still dumb still okay okay so
let's play up c8 still um okay what what
you played is not the best but it's so
sir the maracas see bind we're like a
seven for a long time um yea rather
passive and it doesn't mean that some
inaccurate move gives you an advantage
yeah I played a five very quickly but
asking myself now if this was a good
idea hmm yarn I'd be six is not the most
sophisticated idea but the dough it is
some suddenly am annoying night before
maybe not be 692 mmm-hmm yeah if I force
it was probably just bad played this 32
quickly
alright just I return now with this
piece for all you if I'm able to keep
this pawn it's probably not too bad
let's say night night takes yeah Luke
takes yeah now if I'm able to play b6
crb-6 now I cannot win this no then this
is just probably am still a playable
position then the Queen Silas is pretty
solid for black and so it's an exchange
of course but still not easy to break
down yeah the question is should i take
not easy to save time morning
and what is your queen doing now pretty
good question yeah this was some a bit
lucky this game I just blundered with
them with a five okay so what should I
do now probably just just this should be
it should be the simplest don't want to
give them a big pond now get rid of the
good bishop yeah okay just hear this
piece is a bit down a bit overloaded him
rocked it to coming yeah after the
rookies change the a porn just should
should decide
quite resigned yeah of course this was
lucky he just blundered his queen um
yeah II five was just silly I can should
can play basically any kind of normal
move and I'm okay it's a normal position
somewhere between equal and white
slightly better I just overlooked an
idea for this kind of position is still
not easy to break down because I have to
go inside I'm pretty solid he can't open
the tub easily mm yeah this is of course
funny Bishop d7 is just threatening I'm
still it's not easy for y2 to play a
good move yet Bishop d7 what what watch
what are you doing I've just just show
quickly my computer is on for already
gives black a clear advantage yeah I
didn't didn't really appreciate this in
the game I just made the kind of obvious
moves yeah he must play something
different here we get the night to c5
how do your progress that's difficult
okay so let's try for a new game
I'm trying to keep it down with three
minute games so I but down so not so
easy to to get to get them constantly
aim alright done this is 1 15 min for
change okay my way flayed him so often a
good player all right that's so let's
let's try the the London for once it so
been subject of serious from blacks
point of view and he's playing c5 this
is also what I am recommended 96-yard
see three men and now i'm probably just
not if six
no is taking a sweet time this is very
ambitious and tending our very quick e5
if I go neither three what is he doing
Bishop g4 maybe on g5 in hmm not sure
but ok 9 a-3 yeah it's really going for
it do I have some direct way to try to
refute this on my g5 that's probably not
not call for ok what's so drop it back
ok 2d to our to h4 hmmm no g one looks
weird not h 4 i'm not sure ok let's go
here
alright so probably take and deform to
fight for the light squares so probably
the thing to do so should I take on e5
now it's really a question okay I can I
can play this first this must be all
right I need to open up this position
here probably try to take Bishop c4 and
stuff like that getting cancelled
immediately fled all this porn loses its
no way that this can be really good um
we should be five check around this with
the temple King young should I take only
five I think I should really I don't
want to give you the night don't want to
give the neither square though okay
let's just cancel first
this must be fine really castles the
adobe to take here take on d5 and then
Bishop c4 should be an advantage of
course I could have done I know I
couldn't couldn't have done if i would
have taken on dvd5 before i could have
taken with the Queen okay so let's say I
take now come on I take the snow and
then I take d5 if it takes with the
bishop I can take g4 take with the Queen
i play Bishop c4 yeah okay and I can do
this this is this is clear I need to UM
untangle my night cm9 to reform probably
not only 4 and 9 22 hmm should be fine
922 I saw something something better
okay should be bad one possible ideas to
play Knights you form of course the Sam
can get hairy for the bishop if i play
nazi forward you find for some hanging
with check so this is some possibility
now here to see to probably i want to
get rid of this bishop so that i can
play against reform now threatening
Queen g4 also so just take it and Knight
takes a player 3 and open up the fr this
must be very good for white got this big
night only eight let's just attack the
king away and then play g3 or queen f3
and then g3 something like this g3
I cannot cancel long always need to keep
that in mind you're a queen of cell yeah
maybe you can get something on the
default also know therefore and not c4
of course why didn't look at this at all
96 this is good so I don't want to
exchange Queens ready my dear second I
to e4 next like you form time money and
94 there should be seven hundred sides
really stupid okay maybe I need to
accept the Queen trade it's also a much
better and game if you would right now
so my night is just a much better than
his Bashara kidding me right this is no
job offers really beautiful bit of an
offense here because it's just it's just
really worse until the 90s some downtime
just win the H born black reside yeah
cross the straw for what's a bit strange
oh yeah me just to just wicked himself
too much this was far too risky probably
I had ways to refute this even more
convincing me but I think what was
always clearly better I hope at least
okay so let's try for one last M star
three minutes again I let's go inform
and to cut g 6 cm okay okay okay let's
play a fine FYI always thought this
should be it should be a good line ya
hear what cannot play
very a setup see can I give this check I
can take okay i will take our tech and
now Queen to d4 wasn't this some tricky
line let's try this um should be five
now if i remember correctly i saw this
in some some opening um so away
castleton here I really don't know not
quite sure quindi force a quite a tricky
move but I don't don't really know the
ins and outs he applied pretty quickly
so he wasn't completely surprised
and yeah i'm not sure what black should
do maybe you can just exchange i I
really don't know Wow never thought
about this roof I would take what I
don't get it but take on c6 what happens
Bishop c3 right okay bc Queen takes I
can also check on c5 then okay come on
keep it simple I just I just grabbed
upon him and he's um he's now needs to
proof the compensation for this it's
possible I mean it's not completely out
of this world with rupee aid night see
fire stuff like that maybe I could have
taken already in 95 mmm ok but 95 or so
I could move anyway tacking has some
strength at night and now I get get rid
of this Bishop unknown g7 yeah don't
really see the compensation seems like
white is just a pawn up yeah threat
Knight f6 and 97 okay I can okay i'm
just-just look quickly let's just
protect this first I can take the
exchange later takes on d3 I can yeah
now cover your form and very reliable
web design yum we have some opening
opening miss misstep here I don't know
how this is flight somewhere around here
um but this I don't know looks just like
next respond to me alright thanks for
watching this blitz session and i hope
you enjoyed it